hello everyone just wanted to clarify
something about the machine learning
algorithms that we have on the platform
a quick intro before I jump into it in
the platform on the T bio info platform
we have these data mining sections
called supervised analysis and
unsupervised analysis so again what's
the difference
unsupervised analysis would be things
like clustering PCA where you would kind
of explore the data and identify data
structures that you want to analyze
under supervised analysis we have
classifiers and different methods that
would help you work with the data that
you can label okay so the biggest
difference is that if you don't know
what your samples are you would want to
use unsupervised analysis to explore if
you know some specific things about your
samples for example if you know a class
a subtype or something like that then
you can use the supervised analysis
section okay so I know that a lot of you
had questions about how to exactly use a
supervised analysis and we recently
updated this section so I just want to
show you how to prepare the files and
run the analysis to get results and what
kinds of results would you actually get
okay so I have here a couple of files
one I I call test and another one I call
train now in the new updated version you
actually don't need to test and train
but let's keep it because it will still
be easier for us to use what's the
difference well the difference is that I
have the sample name here on top ID so
this is a table of expression and this
would be something that you get from the
RNA seek section so in RNA seek section
we process the data and we get a table
of expression we have numbers in here
remember that normalization log scale
and what exactly are these numbers is
going to play a big role in your
analysis but we got some table of
expression and what are these these are
gene IDs so these are going to be our
features again what's important here is
the number of features the more features
you have the more samples you should
have
really work with this features so
because you might run into over sitting
but right now I'm just gonna try and do
something that might not make a lot of
sense but at least technically will work
so now here I have a row that's called
class and the class is really my
labeling of the sample so this is
different types of cancers that I have
labeled here they have a bunch of
different samples okay remember class ID
not group not name not ID not anything
like that class with a loader lower seat
all right so let's say this what is in
my test okay so theoretically what is a
classifier used for the classifier is
used to classify some set of samples
based on unknown set of samples so I
have let's say five known samples and
then three unknown samples so I can
train the model using known samples that
are annotated or labeled and then use
that model to classify new samples but a
lot of times what we see in these kinds
of experiments is the need for feature
selection so I want to select the genes
that are responsible for separation
between different classes for example I
have some classes that are cancer some
classes that are normal could I use a
classifier to select those features yes
some versions of classifiers are what's
called greedy algorithms they also
select informative features and others
for example like random forests which
are decision trees they're not really
classifiers but they could be used as
classifiers they also give us some
evaluation of features inside so which
features were used to make those
decisions at different trees okay so
let's try and run this and see what we
get okay so on the platform go to areas
of analysis and select supervised
analysis now let's upload
both of these files so here's the test
here's the Train upload it wait until
it's fully uploaded define groups check
okay this is the training group this is
the test okay what's the difference just
one again training is going to contain
the labels for samples and the test is
not going to contain it and of course it
will very well be up to you what exactly
you put inside but remember your gene
names if those are your features they
have to match exactly the number of
features plays a role the numbers in the
cells also play a role because some of
these methods are actually going to be
assuming different things about those
numbers and if your data set does not
fit those assumptions it will fail okay
but for now let's click on continue
start and let's select stepwise Lda so
stepwise Lda
over here it's a stepwise linear
discriminant analysis is used to find a
subset of the provided features that
optimally separates the classes inherent
in the data okay so this is a
description that you can read more about
but let's look at this picture right
here so this is somewhat like PCA you
have two axes LD 1 LD 2 and LD 3 so you
have different combinations LD 1 and LD
2 LD 1 and of the three LD 2 and LD 3
etc and within you will see your sample
names by class and it will show you how
it separates those different classes
okay now you have here this parameter
nouveau what does it actually do well
it's an internal parameter that is used
to draw that line that separates the
samples typically you would just want to
add another 0 here if you're using the
type of data that I just used and now
you can click on end and then you will
save your pipeline save ok go on you
yeah
step-wise Oda test save it run it okay I
already ran this pipeline so let me just
show you what you get stepwise lva let's
look at pipeline output files what do we
have here so we have a number of files
the first one is a plot let's take a
look at what is in the plot and discuss
a little bit what we see in here okay so
these are all of these different cancers
that we were looking at and now I didn't
really normalize the table or do
anything with the table I just ran it
the way I was given it just to test this
but you can see that the separation is
actually not that great however if you
look further into this pipeline let's
see what else do we get so for example
coefficients these are the coefficients
for features so let's open that file and
let's see what are these features so
these features are going to be genes and
let's see how many we have 50 features
okay so this is a lot but nevertheless
we can now take this list and we can go
back to our expression table and
actually find them okay so let's take a
look for example the first one this is
let's find the training data set and
just search for that so here we go I
found this sample and I'm just going to
mark it right here as one alright why
because it's gonna be easier for me to
find it so let's insert really quickly
okay and let's see why did it choose to
choose this as a good as a good gene so
let's select data and let's just label
this data with row names which is going
to be class so let's go to the very top
and this is going to be our label
okay and press okay all right now let's
go back to to the chart let's take a
look okay so we already saw that it's
not a perfect separation nevertheless we
do see some interesting pattern here so
for example colorectal cancer which is
all right here is all upregulated breast
cancer is all pretty much under
expressed this cancer AMP cancer is also
someone higher pancreatic cancer is
higher so you do see some insight into
the cancers that you're studying using
this gene now how would we choose this
gene not in the same way we could do
differential gene expression so
obviously if we took colorectal cancer
versus breast cancer this would probably
be easy to find using something like
t-test or differential gene expression
but here we actually get more
information that's not just about a pair
it's about multiple types and we have
about 50 genes that are going to be
informative for this kind of separation
okay so I hope that this was informative
in terms of preparing your data and in
terms of running something like stepwise
Lda of course remember that selection of
features and what kinds of numbers you
have inside is all going to play a big
role in how successful you are at
getting results now if you have any
questions make sure to check out the
chat box type us a question we just
reach out to us by email and make sure
you take the courses transcriptomics 3
talks about this procedure over in
greater detail